So, we eventually got to find the x-intercepts of this equation that we didn't
know how to factor, but this is a pretty long winded process. Unfortunately,
this is a situation that we actually run into quite a bit. It's really only very
special cases of quadratic equations that we can factor. Thankfully, there's a
formula that we can use to calculate the roots of a quadratic equation so we
don't have to go through this long process every single time. Now, get excited,
because you are going to work out that formula yourself. We're going to start
with the general form of a quadratic equation, ax squared plus bx plus c equals
0. And we're going to use this to solve for x. This might look a little bit
complicated at certain points but once you've gotten to the end and you
understand why the formula we end up with works, you'll get to use this every
single time. Let's follow this same method as we did in the last example. First
things first, let's complete the square. It might be a little bit messy but
we're going in. The first thing I'd like you to do is to factor out a from these
first two terms here. What belongs inside these parenthesis then?